Ja, okay.
Okay, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Omutel Gigit und heute bin ich der
Insalben der Ars auf der Sästation. Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne das Erstgespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay. Ja, ich möchte zuerst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschweden.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Oder fragen Sie nach.
Alles klar. Sehr gut.
Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Richard Schlenk.
Richard Schlenk.
Herr Schlenk, könnte Sie bitte Ihren Namen ausstabieren?
Vorname oder Nachname?
Nachname.
Ich heiße
Wie viel Sie so seit wiegeln?
Ungefähr 82 Kilo.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Informationen. Herr Schlenk, was für Sie heute sonst, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also, ich habe schon seit einigen Tagen Schmerzen in den Rippen und im Rücken.
Und seit zwei Tagen huste ich auch.
Schmerzen.
Schmerzen in Bruskok, meinen Sie?
Ja, Rippen und Rücken.
Okay. Rücken.
Die Schmerzen in anderen Körperregionen aus, nur ich meine Arme oder Hals.
Nee, das nicht. Nur dort, wo ich gesagt habe.
Ich spüre sie manchmal im Rücken und manchmal tun mir die Rippen so seitlich wie.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie husten haben?
Ja, seit zwei Tagen habe ich husten.
Okay.
Önnten Sie die Schmerzen genau, bei Schmerzen, wenn du rücken, brennen?
Also, das sind mehr so drückend bis technisch, Märzen.
Drückend.
Okay.
Herr Schneck, hatten Sie früher eine Beschwerden?
Ähnliche Beschwerden.
Früher, nee, nee, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Ja, Wichtag sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkeler von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr leid und 10 unerträglichen Schmerzen entspricht.
Also, dann würde ich sagen, das dürfte so 4 und 5 sein.
4 und 5.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Wenn ich nicht tief atme, sind die Schmerzen weniger.
Okay.
So sind die Schmerzen belastungabhängig?
Belastungsabhängig, nur Atemabhängig.
Also je tiefer ich atme, desto mehr habe ich Schmerzen.
Tiefer.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Herr Schneck, jetzt würde ich, möchte ich unser Geschickler unterbringen und ich möchte einige Massnahmen bei Ihnen durchführen.
Ich meine, ich würde eine EKG schreiben und dann ich würde Ihr Sauerstoff-Sätigung messen und ich würde Ihr Körper, Ihr Blunk abhören, wenn alles gut ist.
Lunge, Lunge, abhören.
Ja, die Lunge abhören und wenn alles in Ordnung ist, können wir unser Gespräch fortsetzen.
Okay.
Ja, ist okay.
Ja, ne klar.
Ja, okay.
So, gibt es etwas auffällig bei der Ergebnis oder können wir fortsetzen?
Man bei den Untersuchungen, ob da was auffälliges war jetzt?
Ja, ich meine, okay, so, wir können fortsetzen.
Ja, okay.
Okay, vielen Dank.
So, ja, haben Sie einen Auslöser, der diese Schmerzen bemägt?
Ne, ne gar nicht, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Also, wenn Sie mich so fragen, meine Frau hatte vor zehn Tagen eine Brunchitis gehabt?
Vor zehn Tagen, okay.
Herr Schrenk, haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Ne, bisher noch keine Medikamente, aber die Schmerzen werden mehr, deshalb bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, zu uns zu kommen.
So, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Hüsten haben und seit zwei Tagen Sie Hüsten haben.
Ja.
Könnten Sie die Hüsten genauer beschreiben, eher durchkennt oder mit Auswurf?
Ne, das ist schon teilweise mit Auswurf, also nicht sehr viel.
Ich muss sehr stark Hüsten hin und wieder Hüsten attacken und dann kommt da auch mal was raus, ja?
Mit hösten Attacken, okay.
So, und wie sieht der Auswurf?
Sie meinen jetzt von der Farbe her?
Ja, ich meine Farbe und Konsistenz.
Also, das ist so bisschen gelbgrün.
Okay.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, dass die Hüsten anfällig ist mit Attacken kommen?
Ja, hin und wieder, ja.
Okay.
Wenn Sie mehr Hüsten, morgens, abends oder über Tag?
Den ganzen Tag, auch in der Nacht jetzt.
Ganz in der Nacht, okay.
Herr Schillek, fühlen Sie sich sehr gut oder leiden Sie unter Fieber?
Ich habe es nicht gemessen, aber meine Frau sagt, ich sehe ziemlich rosig aus.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich super, nicht gemessen.
Leiden Sie unter Atemnot?
Atemnot.
Ja.
Ich habe mich nicht kontrolliert.
In Ruhe habe ich keine Atemnot.
Beim Belastung haben Sie?
Also, seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich mich nicht belastet.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber Treppen komme ich noch hoch.
Beim Treppen?
Geht noch.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Schillek, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine geschwollt sind?
Ich habe eine Beine nicht.
Okay.
Herr Schillek, ich habe Ihre Beschwerden verstanden.
Ich würde mich bald um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Bis auf die Beschwerden, die Sie erwähnt haben, gibt es etwas Ungewöhnliches,
dass Sie bemerkt haben.
Sie haben eine Brustschmerz.
Und Sie fühlen sich, wie Frau hat gesagt, dass die Bibel sieht,
aussieht, aber Sie haben die Körpertemperatur nicht gemessen.
Nein, Körpertemperatur habe ich nicht gemessen.
Meine Frau sagt mir nur, ich hätte ein rosiges Gesicht.
Aber die Bibel weiß ich nicht.
Okay, rosiges Gesicht.
Okay.
Aber, was ich noch sagen muss, habe ich vergessen zu sagen,
ich schwitze sehr stark in den letzten Tagen.
Okay, ja.
Und leiden Sie unter auch Nachschuheis.
Ich meine, müssen Sie Ihre Kleidung nachtliches ändern
oder schwitzen Sie in den Nachts auch?
Ja, in den letzten zwei Tagen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch Stoffrost?
Öttelfrost habe ich vor drei, vier Tagen einmal gehabt.
Einmal in drei Tagen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Wie sieht Ihr appartiert aus, hat Sie Ihr appartiert in der letzten Zeit geändert?
In der letzten Zeit heißt es Tage oder Wochen, Monate?
Ja, ich meine, in drei oder vier Tagen.
Oder ja, in zwei Wochen.
Also in den letzten Tagen ist mein Appetit weniger geworden, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Nachschuheis haben.
Leiden Sie unter Schlafstörung.
Ich meine, einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ja, durchschlafen kann ich nicht. Die Husterei quält mich schon.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten, in letzter Monat, ungewollt ab oder zugenommen?
Nee, in den letzten Monaten nicht, nein.
Wie?
Ja, ich muss alles dokumentieren, was Sie erwähnen.
Okay, ja.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihren Vorgeschichte,
Geldreibchen Vorgeschichte.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Krankheiten, dauerhafte Krankheiten?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Suckerkrankheit?
Nein, ich habe keinen Bluthochdruck und auch keinen Diabetes.
Leiden Sie ansonst irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nee, nee, nicht, dass ich gut bin.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde mit der Blenddamen rausgenommen.
Wie alt waren Sie, wenn die Oper hier rüberführt?
Ich glaube, acht oder so war ich gewesen.
Sind bei Ihnen Energien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich bin nicht bekannt, nein.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente, Regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Okay.
Herr Schnäck, sind Sie geimpft?
Geimpft?
Ja, geimpft, ja.
Ich meine gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, gegen Kinderkrankheiten habe ich meinen Eltern als Kind schon impfen lassen.
Das ist richtig.
Und natürlich jetzt gegen Covid in der Hysterie, in der Epidemie.
Okay, gegen...
Und sind Sie gegen...
Gegen, war es nochmal? Ich habe Sie nicht verstanden?
Grippe.
Gegen Grippe, nein, gegen Grippe habe ich mich nicht impfen lassen, nein.
Herr Schnäck, wir sind bald fertig, aber nun hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemein geholfenheitlichen Zustand.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich habe geraucht, aber in den letzten fünf Jahren nicht mehr.
Letzten fünf Jahren, vor fünf Jahren, haben Sie aufgehört, okay.
Wie viel haben Sie früher auch geraucht?
Also ungefähr eine Packung am Tag.
Eine Packung.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Das dürften vielleicht 30 Jahre gewesen sein.
30 Jahre, ja okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu Sie?
Nein, nein, mit Alkohol habe ich nicht ermut.
Haben Sie nie Alkohol getrunken?
Ich mag kein Alkohol, ich vertrag das nicht.
Okay, so haben Sie erfahren, gehen mit Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, nein, Gott bewahrt.
Okay, treiben Sie Sport?
Nein, nein, Sport habe ich keine Zeit.
Okay.
So sind Sie berufstätig?
Ich bin noch berufstätiger.
Alles was arbeiten Sie?
Ich bin Gas-Wasser-Installatörmeister.
Gas-Wasser-Installatörmeister.
Okay, so, wir haben keine Zeit, um Sport zu schreiben.
Okay, das war es dann.
Ja, ich habe jetzt einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familienvorgeschichte.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, meine Eltern sind nicht mehr am Leben.
Meine Beine sind so, woran sind Sie gestorben?
Ihre Mutter und Ihren Vater, ich meine.
Mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall gehabt,
der ist dann kurze Zeit danach gestorben.
Meine Mutter hatte einige Erkrankungen,
hatte, glaube ich, auch Gewährmutterkrebs
und Bluthochdruck.
Sie war lange, lange in Therapie, dann ist selber gestorben.
Ja, Gewährmutterkrebs.
Und Bluthochdruck, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, ja, es tut mir leid.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihr Vater
in kurze Zeit gestorben ist?
Ja, nach einem Schlaganfall, richtig.
Ja, okay.
Wissen Sie, ob er in anderen Erkrankungen
an einem Erkrankungen leide?
Er hatte sonst keine anderen Erkrankungen, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, ja.
Ist er ja gesund?
Er ist gesund, ja.
Gesund, okay.
Herr Schleg, wie ist Ihr Familienstadt, sind Sie verratet?
Ja, ja, ich bin verratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Söhne und eine Tochter.
Sind die Kinder gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja. Gott sei Dank.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, okay. Wollen Sie alle zusammen?
Nein, nein, die Kinder sind schon längst aus der Haus.
Okay.
Sie wohnen mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Schleg, meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Informationen
von Ihnen bekommen.
Möllen Sie etwas hinzufügen, dass ich wissen sollte?
Nein, mir fällt jetzt nichts ein.
Okay.
Eine letzte Frage.
Sind Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten,
ein bisschen wohin gereist, ich meine Inland oder Ausland?
Nein, ich kann mich vor Arbeiter gar nicht retten.
Ich habe keine Zeit zu reisen.
Ja, Sie haben event.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben event, was hinzufügen, bis auch die Beschwerden,
die Sie oben erwähnt haben?
Nein, nein, nicht.
Ja, okay, so, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie, sollten Sie fragen,
da kann ich antworten.
Nein, ich habe keine Fragen.
Daran sind mir nur, warum ich die Schmerzen habe
und können Sie mir etwas dagegen geben?
Ja, natürlich habe ich einige Vermutungen,
aber diese sind nur Verdacht.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und wie ich gesagt habe, einige Massnahmen
bei Ihnen durchführen.
Alle Massnahmen sind wichtig für uns
und nachdem die Ergebnisse,
können wir genau besprechen, darüber besprechen.
Aber jetzt kann ich Ihnen sagen,
das kann eine Lungenentzündung sein
oder eine Entzündung sein
oder das kann eine Brunhitis wie Ihr Frau sein.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe,
zunächst müssen Sie körperlich untersuchen
und einige Massnahmen wie Brutabnahme
und eine Röntgen-Torax durchführen.
Nachdem die Ergebnisse können wir genau besprechen.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut, einverstanden.
Ja, vielen Dank. Bitte.
Danke schön. Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ich glaube, dass die Kollegen
hat eine unvollständige Frage interlassiert, Herr Kollege.
Kollegen, Sie sind los, bitte.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Unfall?
Unfall, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Blut im Auswurf bemerkt?
Nein, nicht.
Danke schön. Bitte.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Unsere Kollegen unterbrechen die Anamnesik-Sprech
und EKG schreiben und Lunge ablaufen.
Wir sind die EKG und Lunge oder sowas Stoffsetkung.
Können Sie bitte erklären?
Am Ende, bitte. Yes, nicht.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es Fragen oder?
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Schützach und Dschmerzen, irgendeinem Aus?
Nein, der Kollege hatte das aber gefragt.
Das ist vielleicht untergegangen. Ausstrahlen tun die Schmerzen nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen mit der Zeit verschlachtet?
Ja, die haben in den letzten Tagen zugenommen.
Okay, das ist das.
Ja, bitte.
Ist Ihnen Hautverpörlenderungen aufgefallen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Rötung oder im Brustbereich besonders.
Im Brustbereich? Rötungen? Nein, nein.
Aber wie gesagt, meine Frau sagt, mein Gesicht sei rosig-rot.
Irin und Stuhl gefragt, oder?
Nein, das würde nicht gefragt.
Ja, ich habe vergessen.
Ja, eine Frage.
Ja.
Was ist Ihnen Schwellung am Haus oder in der letzten Meldung gefolgen?
Schwellungen? Ja.
Nein, ich habe keine Schwellungen bemerkt.
Haben Sie zu Hause Tiere?
Ja, eine Katze, aber sonst nichts.
Haben Sie Kasenhar-Allergie?
Nein, die Katze haben wir schon seit fünf, sechs Jahren.
Wenn dann hätte ich das schon gewusst.
Danke.
Können wir als Geschenk anfangen?
Ja, wir können.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, na klar.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Schlenk ist 63 Jahre alt, 1,46 m und wiegt zur Zeit 82 kg.
Ein Moment, 1,46 m.
76.
1,76, ja, okay.
Ja, der Patient hat uns seit einigen Tagen bestehenden Schmerzen
im Bruchkopf und Rücken drücken,
und er hat nicht mehr Schmerzen gehabt.
Er hat es gehabt?
Ja, er hat es gehabt.
Und die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 4 bis 5 von 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Er hat kein Auslöse bemägt,
aber bei tiefen Atmen verschlechter sich die Schmerzen.
Ja, er hat...
Herr Schlenk.
Er hat eine Inspiration.
Ah ja, Inspiration, beim tiefen Inspiration.
Er hat auch berichtet, dass er seit 2 Tagen
Küsten mit gelblicher und grünem Auswurf gehabt hat.
Die halten ja noch an, das ist ja nicht vorbei.
Er hat seit Tagen grün, gelblichen Auswurf.
Ja, grün.
Wir haben wieder gesagt, Schiputum.
Schiputum, okay.
Ja, und die Hüsten, er haben Hüsten,
ganz und tak, aber mit, die Hüsten kommen mit,
attacken, valent Hüsten.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und es ist erwähnenswert, dass ihr Frau vor 10 Tagen...
Seine Frau.
Ja, seine Frau vor 10 Tagen beschwerden wie Bronitis.
Hat.
Hatte.
Hatte, ja, hatte.
Ja, ihr Frau, ihre Frau hat bemerkt.
Seine Frau, ja.
Ah, ich schuldige Sie, seine Frau.
Seine Frau, sonst ist es falsch, ja.
Ja, seine Frau hat bemerkt, dass sein Gesicht
rosiger aussieht, aber er habe die Körpertemperatur
nicht gemessen.
Zu den Vegetativen beschwerden
nachts weiß Stilfrost einmal in den nächsten 3 Tagen
in Appetence, in Somni, wegen Hüsten.
Ja.
Hyperhydroase.
Ja, und Hyperhydroase.
Hyperhydroase, nicht Hyperhydroase.
Hyperhydroase.
Ja, Hyperhydroase.
Ja.
Ja, keine Vorherrige-Erkrankungen sind
bei den Patienten bekannt.
Mhm.
Mit im Alter von 8, wo der Eier appendoktomiert.
Keine Allergien, oder keine Allergien,
sowie Unverträglichkeiten, sind bei ihm bekannt.
Eier nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig
oder bei Bedarf.
Eier ist voll geimpft, aber ja,
er ist nicht gegen Grippe geimpft.
Die Reise an einem Nest, an einem Nest ist Lea.
Mhm.
Er hat vor 5 Jahren Rauch und Aufgehört,
aber zuvor liegt Nikotin Konsum
bei 30 Jahre lang Einpackung täglich vor.
Er trinkt keine Alkohol und treibt eine Wahrung.
Hojam, kurz 30-Päck-Jahres.
Mhm.
Ja, einpackung täglich 30 Jahre lang,
das bedeutet 30-Päck-Jahres.
Nikotin Konsum beträgt 30-Päck-Jahres.
Ja.
Er treibt eine Support, weil er so beschäftigt ist.
Er arbeitet als Gaswasser-Installaturmeister
und deswegen habe er keine Zeit, um Sport zu treiben.
Sein Vater ist an Apoplex gestorben
und seine Mutter ist an Uteruskarcinum gestorben
und er hatte auch eine Erdbeutung.
Er hat auch Arterialhypertoni geleitet.
Er lebt.
seiner Frau und Katze, ja, die analytischen Angaben, die erhobenen analytischen Angaben,
die am ersten auf eine Pneumonie hin. Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen die
von Brunhittis Grippe in Betracht, um Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen und die Differenzialdiagnose
auszuschließen, werde ich den Patienten zuerst hörellich untersuchen, die Lungen abhören,
die Haars beurteilen. Dann würde ich bei den Patienten Blut abnehmen, besonders
Entzündungsparameter wie CAP und Prochastonin. Dann würde ich eine Brunhittorax
dünn führen. Als Differenzialdiagnosen habe ich auch eine, muss ich eine Lungenembole
auszuschließen, so auch auszuschließen, so bei Brutabnahme kann ich auch ein D-Dimer beurteilen
und bestimmen. Aber passt denn eine Lungenartigeembole zu den genannten Angaben?
Ne, ja, die genannten Angaben sprechen gegen eine Lungenembole, aber ich möchte
ausschließen. Aber sie haben keine Beinödämme, so keine, ja aber Brutschmerzen, ja sie haben
keine, nicht mehr, so und ja die Schmerzen liegen 5 von 10, so ja das ist nur eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Ja, aber man muss nicht jede Differenzialdiagnose abklären, sonst würde man ja sehr viel Geld
auch verlieren, man muss das Wesentliche machen, das was notwendig ist und nicht alles,
was im einem in den Kopf kommt. Eine Lungenartigeembole passt nicht von den Angaben her,
der hat keine Belastungsdüsbne, er hat gesagt er kann Treppen noch gut steigen, ja und er hat keine Reise gehabt,
er war nicht immobil und er hat keine Trombose in der Vergangenheit, also das passt er nicht.
Und was man aber machen sollte, ja erzählen Sie weiter, was wird denn noch ein?
Ja, um eine Myocardinfarkt auszuschließen würde ich eine EKG schreiben, ja, ja aber auch da, das würde man
vielleicht zwar machen wollen, weil er generell Brustschmerzen hat, aber der Kardiologe ist ja auch am Monitor,
ich würde einfach nur eine EKG-Untroponien abnehmen und mehr nicht, ich denke nicht, dass der eine Myocardinfarkt hat,
das passt er nicht dazu, aber man kann es zu sich einmal kontrollieren, vor allem deshalb, weil er eine Raucheranamnes hat.
Der Nikotip Gonsum beträgt 30 Pakonnias und sein Vater, seine Mutter hat eine Leid an Atherialhypertoni.
Ja, nicht Leid, sondern die Mutter leidt an Atherialhypertoni, man muss in der Vergangenheit sprechen, die ist ja schon verstorben.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, und ich würde auch Sauerstoffsetigung messen.
Ja.
Ja, und ich würde auch eine Blutgasanalyse beurteilen.
Ja, Blutgasanalyse machen, eine Atherielle oder eine Benöse.
Ja, bei einem Pinoemoni muss man Atherielle Blutgasanalyse beurteilen.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, ja.
Okay, gut.
Was kann man auch noch machen?
Der hat ja geraucht, wenn das die Klinik bietet, wo sie arbeitet, dann kann man auch eine Lungenfunktion
und Untersuchungen nachmachen.
Ja, die Lungenfunktion, Untersuchungen muss man durchführen.
Ja, ich, ja, nicht so bekannt, aber um eine Rangialkarcinom auszuschließen, kann man auch eine
Borax-Computer-Tomographie durchführen.
Ja, würden Sie jetzt sofort machen?
Ne, ja, ich würde nicht sofort machen.
Ja, ich kann zu einer Brust, klar, was war das, Respiratur, Respiratur, ja, ich habe das
vergessen, der Facharzt für Respiraturische System.
Einfach, ich würde zu einem Facharzt.
Neumologische Vorstellung, meinen Sie?
Ja, ja, neumologische Vorstellung.
Ja, könnt ihr mir mal zwei Minuten Zeit geben, weil mein Akku geht leer, ich muss das
gerade mal anschließen, habe ich jetzt nicht erwartet.
Ich muss gerade mal mein Computer-Anladekabel anschließen.
Auf geht es doch.
Ja, so.
Ja.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ja, jetzt haben Sie den abgehört, was hören Sie denn?
Ich habe einige Geräusche gehört, ich habe feinende Geräusche und Rallye gehört.
Ja, Rasselgeräusche, also entweder haben Sie trockene Rasselgeräusche oder feuchte
Rasselgeräusche, sagen wir dazu, und man muss auch die Lokalisation sagen,
wo Sie diese Rasselgeräusche hören, in den Basalen, in den unteren
Abschnitten oder im mittleren Abschnitt oder im oberen Abschnitt, das muss
man schon erwähnen.
Aber wenn der Mann jetzt sagt, er hat so Rippenschmerzen und im
dritten Abschnitten, dann wird das wahrscheinlich eher so basale
Abschnitte sein.
Und jetzt ist die Frage rechts, links, wo haben Sie das gehört?
Und wahrscheinlich hat er dann mehr rechts als links, rechts basale,
feuchte Rasselgeräusche.
Aber auch teilweise vielleicht Gemen.
Warum?
Warum könnte er noch ein Gemen haben?
Das kann eine Brut sein, meine Sie.
Nein, der hat geraucht, der kann natürlich auch eine COPD noch haben,
ohne dass es bisher festgestellt wurde, auch wenn er keine Luftnote
angibt.
Und jetzt, wo er eventuell eine Pneumonie hat, kann es auch zu
Gemen führen.
Und deshalb muss man genau hinhören, sind das mehr nur feuchte
Rasselgeräusche oder gibt es auch robblasige Rasselgeräusche,
das ist zum Beispiel Gemen.
Ob man dann Gemen hört, ja oder nein, ob das nur feinblasiges
Knistern ist zum Beispiel, dass man das dann auch so mal
abgehört hat.
Gut.
Jetzt haben Sie ihn abgehört und Sie sagen, der hat so
verdächtige feuchte Rasselgeräusche rechts basale.
Sie haben ihn ja auch zum Röntgen geschickt.
Was erwarten Sie jetzt vom Röntgen?
Ja, ich erwarte Konsolidation beim Röntgen.
Ja.
Ja, im Basale oder ja, man muss der Abschnitt bestimmen,
aber man kann Konsolidationen sehen.
Ja, man spricht man, ja, dieser Begriff mit Konsolidation,
das ist mehr so ein radiologischer Begriff.
So klinisch spricht man im Deutschen immer von Infiltrationen.
Infiltrate, Infiltrationen.
Konsolidierend, das ist mehr so ein radiologischer Begriff.
Den Sie eher so benutzen, aber wir würden eher von Infiltraten
sprechen.
Ja.
Gut.
Und Sie haben sicherlich auch die Sauerstoffsättigung
gemessen.
Und was haben Sie da gesehen?
Was für eine Sauerstoffsättigung hat er?
Ja, das kann, ich glaube, niedrig sein.
Niedrig sein?
Ja, was erwarten Sie denn?
Wenn er jetzt so diese Pneumonie, die Sie jetzt
radiologisch und klinisch jetzt festgestellt haben,
was erwarten Sie denn für eine Sättigung bei dem?
Ja, das kann zum Beispiel 90 Prozent sein,
oder so ein bis, ja, 85 bis 92 Prozent sein.
Vorsicht, da sind Sie jetzt in der Falle getappt.
Wenn Sie eine Sättigung von 85 angeben,
was müssen Sie mit dem Mann so fortun?
Ja, man muss Sibap oder Bipap angeben.
Der muss auf die Intensivstation, ja, da müssen Sie vorsichtig sein.
Also, wenn Ihnen jemand gegenüber sitzt, der normal mit Ihnen noch sprechen kann,
kann der keine Sättigung unter 90 Prozent haben.
Ja, aber jemand mit 85er Sättigung, der ist schon intensivpflichtig,
den müssen Sie ganz schnell hoch tun, da haben Sie nicht die Zeit,
einer Anamnese zu führen.
Da müsste Sie vorsichtig sein.
Also, wenn jemand in den Notaufnahme kommt, ja, mit solchen Beschwerden,
dann müssen Sie nicht lange mit Anamnese aufhalten,
sondern Sie müssen ihn erstmal klinisch ganz schnell untersuchen.
Ja, Sie nehmen einfach hier Stethoscope, hören ihn ab, ja,
und dann gucken Sie ganz schnell mal nach der Sättigung,
dann haben Sie das Wichtigste schon erreicht, ja.
Und dann wissen Sie, ob Sie sich mit dem noch unterhalten können,
oder ob Sie den ganz direkt auf eine Intensivstation schicken müssen.
Weil sonst kann es passieren, dass der Patient instabil wird,
vorsichtig.
Gut, sagen wir mal, der hat eine 92er Sättigung.
Okay.
Und jetzt nehmen Sie ihm noch Blut ab.
Und Sie hatten ja schon gesagt,
CRP gucken Sie sich an, Prokalsytonin und natürlich Blutbild.
Und was sehen Sie da?
Wie hoch sind so die Leukozytten?
Was schätzen Sie mal?
Ja, eine kann erhöht sein.
Der Erzümbungssparme, das CRP, Prokalsytonin und Leukozytten erhöht sein.
Ja, die werden erhöht sein.
Die können nicht, die werden erhöht sein, bei den klinischen Welten.
Nehmen wir mal an, er hat ein CRP nicht von 5, nicht von 10,
sondern der hat ein CRP von über 30,
wenn man bedenkt, dass der Referenzwert bis 0,5 geht,
dann ist das sehr, sehr hoch.
Und der hat Leukozytten von 30.000.
Prokalsytonin ist sehr, sehr hoch, was weiß ich, bei 7,8,
so um den Drehung.
7,8.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt daraus?
Ja, jetzt zuerst würde ich sauber Stoff geben,
dann, ja, ich würde auch Handstoff, ich muss auch Handstoff messen,
um eine CRP 5,60, ja, ich würde CRP 5,60 beurteilen,
ob Konfession oder Bilonstatuz, Gut- und Respirator-Rate
auch diese Hypotension gibt, dann, wenn diese Risikofaktoren,
eine von dieser Risikofaktoren gibt, würde ich den Passagierstationen aufnehmen.
Ja, also wenn jemand jetzt mit so einer Klinik kommt,
den muss man sogar stationär aufnehmen,
da würde ich nicht nach irgendwelchen Kriterien gucken,
der hat eine nachgewiesene Pneumonie,
ja, radiologisch im Röntgen-Torax, der hat sehr hohe Entzündungswerte,
den können Sie nicht ambulant behandeln, das geht gar nicht,
das dürfen Sie nicht, ja, und der hat eine Sättigung grenzwertig von 92%,
da müssen Sie nicht auf die Hypotonier achten,
ob er jetzt die hastolischen Druck von irgendwas weiß ich, 50 hat
oder es ist historisch unter 100 hat, das sind,
meiner Meinung nach irrelevante Kriterien, die stehen nicht im Vordergrund, ja,
das ist einer, aber das zweite ist, jetzt haben Sie so bestimmte Sachen vor sich,
was machen Sie jetzt mit den Ergebnissen?
Machen Sie Behandlung?
Ja, ja, jetzt haben Sie ja Ihre Diagnose,
aber da hat irgendjemand auch richtigerweise einen Einwand jetzt da reingebracht
und sagt, was macht man in solch einem Falle,
wenn man sieht, der hat hohe Entzündungswerte,
Leukozytten sind hoch und Sie sehen eine Pneumonie,
was macht man denn zur Sicherheit bei dem?
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, würde ich sauber Stoff abnahme
und gegebenenfalls BIPAP oder CIPAP durchführen?
Ne, so weit ist der nicht,
wir hatten gesagt, der hat eine Sättigung von 92%
und damit ist der erst mal jetzt nicht beatmungspflichtig,
aber jetzt haben Sie eine Pneumonie festgestellt.
Wir haben im Sauerstoff gegeben, das ist gut, ja, was noch?
Ja, ich würde Antibiotikum verordnen.
Ja, aber was sollten Sie vorher noch machen?
Meinen Sie Blutkultur?
Ja, sehr gut, weil Sie wissen nicht,
mit welchem Keim Sie zu tun haben,
Sie müssen ja empirisch an die Sache rangehen,
aber Sie möchten vielleicht auch wissen,
mit welchem Keim Sie zu tun haben,
wenn die Antibiose in den nächsten Tagen nicht greift,
dass sie dann gezielt die Therapie umstellen können.
Welche Gruppe haben Sie am besten?
Ja, weil darin liegt jetzt die Kunst,
jetzt muss man sich vernünftig einordnen können.
Woran, wovon hängt es ab, welches Antibiotikum Sie geben?
Ja, sonst würde ich Penicillin oder Macrolitin
wie Coa-Erythromicin, Erythromicin oder Acidromicin.
Warum wollen Sie ein Macrolit geben direkt?
Ja, erst würde ich Beta-Lactam, Antibiotikum,
aber wovon hängt es ab, welches Antibiotikum Sie dann wählen?
Das ist eine Community-Pneumonie.
Ambulant erworbene Pneumonie, das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Jetzt müssen Sie aber mal Ihren Patienten vor Augen halten.
Die Angaben richtig hinhören, wie sah sein Sputum aus?
Ja, gelblich und grünisch.
Ja, gelb passt zu was?
Ja, Stepp-Cocon-Pneumonie.
Ja, irgendwelche banalen Penicillin-empfindlichen Keime,
ob das jetzt Streptococcus sind oder ob das jetzt Pneumococcus sind,
das sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber Penicillin oder Derivate würden da schon mal werken.
Aber der grünliche Anteil, würden Sie das dann mit Beta-Lactam-Antibiotika
irgendwie behandeln können?
Nicht so.
Ja.
Grün wird nicht helfen.
Und da haben Sie Recht, da müssen Sie dann Macrolit geben.
Aber in dem Falle, darauf wollte ich nämlich hinaus,
nicht entweder oder Sie müssen beides geben in dem Falle.
Warum?
Ja, damit Sie beides können.
Bitte?
Warum beides?
Ja, weil sonst kriegen Sie die, die,
die atypischen Keime, die für die grünlichen Auswürfe zuständig sind,
nicht weg.
Und das dritte Kriterium ist, der Mann hat geraucht.
Ja.
Und Raucher können atypische Keime in sich haben.
Aber dann habe ich Ihnen noch eine Information gegeben.
Auf dem Kopf ist keiner jetzt irgendwie aufmerksam geworden,
sage ich mal.
Was ist der Mann von Beruf?
Ja.
Er arbeitet aus Gas, Wasser und Sledwaremeister.
Legionellenphänomen.
Sehr gut.
Das ist nämlich die Hauptaussage gewesen.
Legionellen.
Wo befinden sich denn Legionellen immer?
Ja.
Klima, ich finde nicht nur was.
Nicht nur.
Nicht nur Klimaanlage, das ist ein Irrtum.
Auch in Wasserleitungen.
Was dann?
Der Mann, das ist sein Beruf.
Er repariert irgendwelche Klimaanlagen oder irgendwelche
Gaswasserleitungen.
Und der kann natürlich auch mit Legionellen zu tun haben.
Ja.
Und wie kriegen Sie raus, ob der eine Legionellose hat
und Legionellen Präumonie hat?
Ja, das war ein Matrium.
Meinen Sie, ein Natriumwerte?
Ne, Sie können das mit einem Test ganz schnell feststellen.
Gut.
Bitte?
Ich trage mich abstrich.
Ne.
Legionellen Antigen im Urin.
Was bedeutet das?
Erst mal, ich habe gehört.
Das erste Mal gehört Legionellen Antigen im Urin.
Ja.
Also wenn Sie ganz schnell so jemanden mal abklären möchten,
ob er eine Legionellose hat oder nicht,
ob er vielleicht auch ein Legionellner krank ist,
einfach Urin wegschicken und Legionellen Antigen hinterfragen.
Wenn der positiv ist, haben Sie nachweis,
dass der Mann möglicherweise eine Legionellen Präumonie hat.
Ja.
Und die Therapie der Wahl bei Legionellose ist,
ein Makulit.
Ja.
Und dann hätten Sie das auch mit abgedeckt.
Also Sie haben schon drei, vier Gründe,
weshalb Sie ein Makulit reingeben müssen, aber nicht alleine.
Ja.
Der hat einen gründlichen Auswurf, der hat geraucht
und der ist von Beruf Gaswasserinstallateur.
Und damit haben Sie den Verdacht auf eine Legionellose.
Und jetzt haben Sie die Antibiotese gewählt, Makulit,
und dann würden Sie noch ein Penicillinderivat geben.
Also, was gibt es, geben Sie dann so üblicherweise?
Die haben gesagt, es ist eine ambulante erborene Präumonie,
keine hospitalisierte Form.
Ja.
Was gibt man da, was würden Sie dann so geben?
Was ist denn das übliche, was Sie so kennen?
Ein Außerantibiotikum, meine Sie?
Ja, als Antibiotikum.
Was ist das für ein Antibiotikum? Würden Sie dann wählen?
Ja, am Sinschubaktam oder Zephthriaxon,
Zephadasporingen, Zephthriaxon.
Ja, Zephthriaxon gibt man nicht mehr so viel.
Ich weiß nicht, wer das so fragt oder so gibt,
aber Zephtriaxon macht zu viele Resistenzen.
Und Zephthriaxon führt zur Bildung von sogenannten ESBL-Bildnern.
Ja, oder 3-MGN, 4-MGN Keimen.
Deswegen ist in Deutschland die Bemühung da,
den Einsatz von Zephthriaxon so weit wie möglich zu reduzieren.
Erste Generation oder zweite Generation Zephalosporine kann man geben,
aber dritt Generation Zephalosporine gibt man nicht mehr.
Nicht, wenn es nicht sein muss.
Ja, also kein Rözefin oder kein andere Sorte
von dritt Generation Zephalosporine sofort geben.
Aber Ampicillin-Sul-Baktam ist gut.
Wenn Sie noch ein bisschen sicher gehen wollen,
können Sie sogar auch Piperazilin dazu Baktham geben.
Das ist ein bisschen breit so fast.
Das können Sie aber machen.
Und als Makrolet dürfen Sie sich aussuchen, was Sie geben wollen.
Ob Sie Klaritromycin geben wollen,
Erritromycin oder Acetromycin,
das bleibt Ihnen über das.
Ja, okay.
Ja, gut.
Und was Sie gesagt haben, was geben Sie denn dann noch?
Jetzt haben Sie nur der Erkrankung behandelt, aber nicht den Patienten.
Was hat der Patient für Beschwerden?
Ja, er hat, ich glaube, ja, und so muss man auch
eine viel Antipyretikum, ich würde auch verordnen.
Ja, aber mit welchen Beschwerden kann er dann zu Ihnen?
Also das Wesentliche, nicht vergessen, nicht verlieren.
Ja, Schmerzen.
Schmerzen, sehr gut.
Also die Schmerzen müssen Sie,
dem Patienten geht es erstmal um die Schmerzen.
Sie müssen eben einen Schmerzmittel geben.
Jetzt frage ich Sie mal, wenn jemand eine Pneumonie hat,
warum kriegt er denn Schmerzen?
Ja, so.
Vor allem beim Einatmen, vor allem Rhythmenschmerzen.
Ja, bei diesem Infiltrationen?
Wegen Infiltrationen.
Ja, aber was machen die dann meistens?
Infiltrationen, was machen?
Ne, solche Infiltrationen führen zu Begleitpläuritäten.
Pläuritischmerzen.
Ja, und was Sie dann meistens aber auch bei solchen Fällen sehen ist,
dass solche eine Pläuritis auch zur Egusbildung führt.
Ne?
Also auch ein Plurre-Egus kann schon mal entstehen.
Und das ist dann auch Schmerzer, pläuritischer Schmerz.
Was geben Sie dann also?
Sie geben Schmerzmittel, etwas, was auch irgendwie antientzündlich ist.
Ja, in dem Falle können Sie etwas geben,
Ibuprofäen geben oder Voltaureen geben.
Da müssen Sie nur aufpassen,
dass Sie das nicht unkontrolliert für längere Zeit geben,
dass Sie keine Magen- oder Darmprobleme entwickeln.
Aber vorübergehend können Sie mit Ibuprofäen,
gegebenenfalls auch ein Magen-Schutz, reingehen.
Ne?
Und dann hatte da jemand noch einen sehr vernünftigen Einwand.
Der Mann hat Sputum.
Was gibt man da noch?
Kann man auch sehr, sehr Mucolithikum verordnen.
Ja, auch Mucolithiker geben.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Und was auch noch?
Mucolithiker alleine reichen nicht aus.
Was brauchen die noch, damit sich der Schleim löst?
Meinen Sie Antitussiva?
Nein, Antitussiva würde ich nicht geben.
Warum nicht?
Ja, man muss Mucolithikum.
Ja, aber kein Antitussiva.
Wenn Sie Antitussiva geben, dann bleibt der Schleim unten.
Sie wollen das heraus haben.
Das soll schon husten.
Aber können Mucolithiker alleine werken?
Nicht mal muss trainieren, mit z.B. Pylpieren.
Ne, aber da hat jemand das Richtige schon hingeschrieben.
Sie brauchen viel Flüssigkeit dazu.
Mucolithiker alleine reichen nicht aus.
Entweder trinkt dieser Mensch noch sehr viel dazu,
oder sie müssen dem Infusionen geben.
Ohne Flüssigkeit kann nämlich Acetyl-Zystein gar nicht wirken.
Das sind die sogenannten Dysulfitbrücken.
Die brauchen viel Flüssigkeit, damit der Schleim zersetzt werden kann.
Wie viel Antikon?
Also, wenn man muss Folgendes überlegen, ja,
nur durch Fieberschwitzerei verliert man zusätzlich ungefähr ein Liter.
Und wenn ein Mensch ungefähr ein Liter trinkt, dann trocknet er aus.
Das heißt, sie müssen dem Mindestens 2-3 Liter am Tag geben,
in der Anfangsphase.
Jetzt nicht 5-6 Tage, vielleicht 2-3 Tage, 2 Liter, 3 Liter,
und dann ganz schnell wieder reduzieren,
wenn der Körper sich wieder einigermaßen stabilisiert hat.
Aber der braucht neben der Mucolithiker auch viel Flüssigkeit dazu.
Sonst funktioniert das leider.
Das muss man wissen.
Antibiotikum, Mucolithiker,
und was man auch noch machen kann.
Der Mann hat jetzt Schmerzen, Atemtraining.
Man kann eben so einen Triflo geben,
wo sie dann selber so einatmen, so Bälle anziehen können.
In manchen Kliniken gibt es auch so Vibratortherapie, sagt man,
wo dann durch die Physiotherapie so ein Gerät auf die Lunge gelegt wird,
der vibriert dann die Lunge, damit sich das Schleim auch lösen kann.
Aber wenn der Mann aktuell Schmerzen hat,
würde ich das jetzt erst mal noch nicht machen.
Und, was wir am Anfang auch gesagt haben,
noch eine Lungenfunktion, um zu sehen,
ob er eventuell auch noch COPD-Komponenten mit dabei hat.
Ob der eine obstruktive Ventilationstörung
oder restriktive Ventilationstörung hat,
oder ob vielleicht sogar auch eine respiratorische Störung
eingetreten ist oder nicht.
Gut.
Soweit verstanden den Ablauf?
Ja.
Gut.
Noch Fragen.
Also, wir haben den Verdacht bei Ihnen jetzt
auf eine legionelle Enthmonie.
Die Antibioser haben Sie ihm jetzt gegeben
und Sie haben Blutkulturen abgenommen.
Sie haben legionellen Antigenemurinen abgenommen.
Sie geben im Flüssigkeit Schmerzmittel
und schicken den auf die Station.
Ja.
Seine Frau,
vor zehn Tagen,
eine Branche hat
Anstieg in der Enthition.
Ja, das kann die Ursache dafür gewesen sein.
Aber häufig ist es so,
dass Leute, die geraucht haben
oder eben mit gefährlichen Keimen zu tun haben,
manchmal einen Trigger brauchen.
Ja, es kann sich nicht so gut aussehen.
Es kann sein,
dass er vielleicht eine virale Infektion
von der Frau abbekommen hat
und dass das Ganze dann einfach bakteriell
superinfiziert ist.
Eine Kollegin hat bei der
Arztpatiente, die ich eine Frage gestattet.
Welche Frage, Kollegin?
Da ging es, glaube ich, um Sättigung
oder irgendwas, wollte Sie wissen, ne?
Ich denke, das war es gewesen.
Die Frau Blumma.
Ich habe gefragt,
wie ist die EKG-Ergebnisse
und die Abhörung?
Sie hat,
die Lungenfektion, sie hat gesagt,
EKG, ich denke, nicht problematisch.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und,
ich habe noch eine.
Eine.